[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHILD: Alexa, turn
off the lights.
AMAZON ALEXA: OK.
CHILD: [GIGGLING] Alexa,
turn on the lights.
AMAZON ALEXA: OK.
SARAH HANSEN: Today on Chalk
Radio, robots and humans become
collaborative partners.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL:
It's not about,
let's build machines
that look like people
and act like people.
It's, let's build machines
that dovetail with us in a way
that we can bring
forth all of ourselves
to help us achieve
the goals that
are really important to us.
SARAH HANSEN: I'm your
host, Sarah Hansen.
This week, we're talking with
a researcher and educator who's
working to bridge the gap
between human well-being
and artificial intelligence.
From kindergarten to
college classrooms,
she's preparing
the next generation
of informed technology users
and empathetic designers.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL:
I'm Cynthia Breazeal.
I am a professor at
MIT at the Media Lab.
I am also director of a
new MIT-wide initiative
called Responsible AI for Social
Empowerment and Education.
We call it RAISE for short.
And I very recently am the
Dean for Digital Learning.
SARAH HANSEN:
Cynthia's fascination
with artificial intelligence
began a long time
ago in a galaxy far, far away.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL: When I
was 10, I saw Star Wars.
And that forever
shaped my, I guess,
vision of what a
robot could be for us.
I mean, it wasn't just
a mindless automaton.
It was an entity that had--
in the movie, they were
full-fledged characters.
Right?
They had friendships.
They were mission-driven
to save the universe.
I mean, all of that.
And, of course, they
had relationships,
not just with the
robots but with people.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Cynthia
followed that vision
of complex human-machine
relationships all the way
to a PhD program at MIT.
There she designed Kismet, the
world's first social robot.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL: That kind
of started this whole question
of socially and emotionally
intelligent interaction
with machines, because we
are profoundly socially
and emotional creatures.
If we want to
design technologies
that can interact with us and
treat us, again, as people,
we need to understand
that dimension.
A lot of the early
work was pushing
on I would say the
algorithmic side of that.
We looked at a lot of models
of emotion, and people,
and animals, and what
is the function of it?
And how might you
implement aspects
of that for intelligent
communication and interaction
with machines?
And then we started
thinking about, OK,
so what's this really good for?
So it's fascinating from
a scientific perspective.
It's fascinating from a
technical perspective.
But what does this
mean about how
we will interact with robots,
with intelligent machines
in our lives, in our future.
And so then we started
thinking about,
so what are these big societal
challenges that we face where
potentially an AI cut more
from this kind of cloth
or this philosophy might
really make a difference?
SARAH HANSEN: After
Kismet, Cynthia
began working on a new
social robot named Jibo.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL:
Jibo is actually
these concentric
rotating circles
that are kind of off-axis.
And with that, he
can kind of create
what's called an
animational line of action.
So he can change his posture.
Right?
So he can look
like he's upright.
Or he can stoop over or lean
to the side and cock his head.
He can go through all of these
kind of expressive postures
that are really foundational
to an animator when
they want to express
something through characters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Technologies tend to move
in rectilinear trajectories.
Living things move in arcs.
And so all of Jibo's
motions was based on arcs.
Right?
So he naturally moved in a
way that just seemed much more
lifelike and expressive,
because he fundamentally
was designed to move in arcs.
You have to see Jibo move.
You have to actually
watch them dance.
Because it's incredible
to watch this robot dance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Jibo didn't
just look and move differently
from other robots.
He functioned differently too.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL: I often
use the language of there's
the Digital Assistant.
Like, this is what
like Google and--
they're all called
digital assistants.
And they're kind of modeled
after the executive assistant.
We talk about Jibo as
being a helpful companion.
So that speaks more to
the social, emotional,
the relational aspects of it.
But Jibo is also helpful.
He can actually do things.
But it's the way he does things
are much more humanistic, I
would say, human-centered in
its design, less transactional.
The way he expresses
himself through movement
and also just the language
he uses, it's much more warm,
I would say.
Like there's cool tech.
Jibo is warm tech.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: One exciting
new application for Jibo
that's currently
being explored is
how he might help provide
mental health care.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL:
One of the studies
we did, we literally designed
an emotional wellness coach
skill for Jibo.
And we deployed Jibo
in MIT student dorms.
Because as you probably know,
mental health is a huge issue.
I mean, even before the
pandemic, mental health,
emotional wellness of students
at a lot of top colleges
was really concerning.
So we decided to explore whether
Jibo as an emotional wellness
coach could actually help
mitigate the stress and anxiety
that students
experience when they're
at an elite university like MIT.
So we developed some
best-in-breed therapeutic
interactions that
typically a human would do,
like a coach would do with
their client or whatever.
So typically it's human-human.
We took these proven
methods and we just,
now Jibo is just doing
it with the person.
And we published that work.
And basically the
punch line is we
were able to show
that, yeah, Jibo seemed
to make a positive difference.
So in terms of the
future of health,
people could go into
hospitals potentially
and get world-quality care.
But what happens
when they go home?
So again, something like
a Jibo, or a social robot,
or whatever, the idea that they
can extend the quality of care
and support from the doctors
and nurses in the hospital
to the home where patients
are living every day, that's
a huge unmet need.
And that's a role
where potentially I
think an intelligent kind
of, again, collaborative
allied agent with this different
kind of interaction paradigm
could make a big difference.
SARAH HANSEN: One of
the fascinating design
decisions behind Jibo
was choosing just
how human to make him.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL: When
we developed Jibo,
we were very
intentional in saying
there's the character of Jibo.
When you talk about
the perception of how
children or adults
perceive these agents,
Jibo as the character was very
aware that Jibo was a robot.
And if you tried to ask
Jibo things that really
a robot would have no
business answering,
like things around religion or
whatnot, Jibo would say this,
like hey, I'm just a robot.
You know, that's
probably something
that'd be good to talk
about another person with.
But I'm just a robot.
So Jibo was very
upfront and transparent
about his robot-ness.
[LAUGHS]
SARAH HANSEN: Collaborative
allied agents like Jibo
have huge potential to
improve the lives of humans.
But as Cynthia pointed out,
they can't replace the power
of real human social networks.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL: This
gets into the ethics
and the responsible
design of these things.
I think, first and foremost,
people need people.
We need our human social
networks, our in-person,
caring human social
networks to come around us
when we're in trouble.
Social media companies
will try to tell you
your network of 5,000
people you don't know
is just as important as
your actual, real, in-person
relationships.
Real, in-person relationships
are absolutely essential.
They're essential
for our well-being.
They're essential for
children's development.
I mean, they're just critical.
And so it signals, I think
we're living in this time
when people's time and
attention has become
this incredibly
precious resource where
the fact that someone will stop
and take that time out for you
signals something
of you're valued.
You are really valued,
and you're meaningful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: As a
parent, the importance
of real social
networks for children
really feels true to me.
But I also know that my child
is growing up in a world
where digital
interactions are becoming
more and more common
and potentially fraught
with ethical implications.
So I shared with
Cynthia a recording
of my child talking with our
home executive assistant.
CHILD: Alexa, what's
your favorite color?
AMAZON ALEXA: I
like ultraviolent.
It glows with everything.
And here's another
fun fact about me.
If you'd like, I
can learn your voice
to do all sorts of neat things
like greeting you by name.
You'll need your own profile.
I can create one for you now.
What's your name?
CHILD: Alexa, off.
AMAZON ALEXA: I'll
create a new profile
and send information
about Alexa terms
and our privacy
notice to your app.
Should I go ahead and create
a profile with the name "Off?"
Parent: "Alexa, off."
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL: Yeah.
So as illustrated by that clip,
kids are growing up in a time
when they will have always
been able to talk and interact
with intelligent machines, and
not just in this verbal way
that we heard in the
clip, but hidden ways.
Right?
So when you're on
social media and it's
trying to learn kind of
what your preferences are,
and giving you
recommendations that
are not trying to broaden
your perspective but
if anything narrow, and
narrow, and narrow, and narrow.
Or of course what we're learning
is, what gets your attention?
What tends to get shared?
Things that really upset you.
[LAUGHS] Those are the things
that really-- you know?
So that's what it
tends to feed you
surprisingly quickly, right?
So it's important for
people of all ages,
but I think it's
important for kids.
Because the average
age of when kids
get their first smartphone,
it's like 10 years old.
And social interaction
through technology
becomes such a key way they
interact with each other.
So the digital
mediated communication
is, it just becomes such
an important way for them
to connect and
express themselves.
And just understanding what's
under the hood, how it could
be biasing, shaping their
attitudes, potentially shaping
behaviors.
This is what's really critical--
and why.
Who's doing it and why?
SARAH HANSEN: That's
where RAISE comes in.
RAISE, which stands for
Responsible AI for Social
Empowerment and Education,
is an MIT initiative
focused on exactly these
kinds of questions.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL: It's kind
of the cross section of AI
and learning, AI and education.
So how can we develop
AI systems that
help us learn, as well as
how can we understand how
to best empower people to
learn about AI so that they
can be informed citizens in how
they use these technologies?
And how do we cultivate
the future designers
of these technologies that
are responsible and ethical
in their designs, but also a
far more diverse and inclusive
future workforce?
We love to position the
student as the designer
of these technologies, so
as the active person who's
thinking about the design, the
social implications, the goals,
all of that.
It really empowers
students in a way
that they lean in, and discuss
and are invested in it.
I think you want
children to grow up,
students to grow up
with the attitude
that I actually can
shape these things.
This is a world that I can be
in, and belong in, and shape.
We have both a research
kind of objective.
We have an outreach,
k-12 outreach, objective.
And a lot of that is
bringing these materials
to teachers and students
of underrepresented,
under-resourced schools
and communities.
Because the field is not
diverse or inclusive.
We need to take action
to correct that.
And so we have an explicit
diversity and inclusion
mission in what we're
doing through the outreach.
And we are trying to design
the curriculum, the concepts,
the activities to
meet students where
they are in things that they
use and they think about so it's
super relevant to them now.
But then we also expose them
to the way AI is transforming
so many disciplines, and
markets, and industries
so they understand
it's here and it's
going to continue to
shape our futures.
SARAH HANSEN: Part
of that work involves
offering an opportunity for
young people and their teachers
across the country to
participate in the upcoming
Day of AI on May 13th, 2022.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL:
We develop all kinds
of curriculum of different
formats and different lengths.
So Day of AI is the
introductory experience.
And it's really an opportunity,
if teachers or students
are just curious about AI,
it is literally a program
intended to be for
any kind of teacher,
for students from elementary
up to high school,
where they can learn
about AI from more
of the lens of its implications
on digital literacy
and digital citizenship, but
also demystifying it as well.
So all great bands
kind of have this,
what is AI introductory module?
So for instance, like
when I spoke about this AI
and creativity curriculum, we've
had students who are saying,
I didn't think I was
relevant or important to me
because I want to be a
photographer when I grow up.
But they're like,
now I realize, wow,
AI could actually be a
really cool tool that I
can use creatively in my
profession of photography
when I grow up.
So a lot of this just to help
kids to understand that chances
are, this is something
that's going to be
empowering and relevant to you.
So just be aware of it,
being able to leverage
it to help you
achieve your goals
and your ambitions in life.
SARAH HANSEN: Well.
If there's a teacher
out there like me
who sometimes can't even get
her agent to turn the lights on,
is this still appropriate?
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL: Absolutely.
So it's for all
kinds of teachers.
Right?
This is not a technical,
computer science,
STEM curriculum at all.
It's really much
more around, again,
digital citizenship and digital
literacy as it pertains to AI,
so again, AI in our lives,
and understanding that,
and having conversations
about that,
and designing some cool
things around that.
[LAUGHS]
SARAH HANSEN: Yeah.
So where can teachers
go to sign up?
And is there a fee associated?
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL: So it's free.
Again, one of the
great things about MIT
is we want to lower the barrier
as much as humanly possible.
So all the materials are free.
You can go to DayofAI.org.
You can look at the
curriculum right there.
We also offer free
teacher training.
You can register
and you can sign up
for an online training session.
We are collaborating
with I2 Learning.
This is a company that what
they do is train teachers.
This is what they do.
And so we've worked with them to
take our curriculum materials,
and using kind of their
experience to really tune it
for what they think
is great for, again,
a broad, general
teacher audience.
And they are running the
teacher training sessions.
And again, it's completely free.
So we would love for
teachers to sign up.
We are in almost
all 50 states now.
[LAUGHS]
SARAH HANSEN: RAISE
and the Day of AI
are increasing access
to AI education.
And they're also
informing how we teach it.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL: It
is an open question
still about what are the most
effective ways of educating
students at a variety
of ages and backgrounds
about what artificial
intelligence is
and how it works.
We still have much
we need to understand
in terms of what grades,
what preparation,
what concepts, how
can we demystify
and these computational
methods in a way that's
grade and age-appropriate?
How we can prepare
teachers-- there's
a whole bunch of
research questions there.
What are the right
approaches, methods
of professional development
for teachers who, I mean,
I can tell you.
They didn't major in
AI in college, right?
So this is new to them too.
So how do we do
that effectively?
What are the longer
impacts of this
in terms of attitudes
and dispositions
that students may form
about these technologies,
and about themselves,
and their relationship
to these technologies?
And then as we do this, how do
we again holistically develop
the whole person as well?
So teamwork, collaboration,
communication,
critical thinking, creative--
they can all be kind of woven
into this tapestry of how
we try to address AI
literacy through positioning
students as the
designers, and creators,
and makers of these solutions
with these technologies.
So we design these activities.
And then we evaluate them.
Right?
So we will reach out and
recruit students and teachers.
And we will engage them.
We often engage in
co-design with them.
So even as we're
developing these materials,
we will work with
teachers and students
as we develop them to make
sure that they're effective,
and responding, and engaging.
And then we do
rigorous evaluations
of what are they understanding
or not understanding?
What is their pathway
to understanding?
And what is the
implication of that
for how we think about staging
these concepts and ideas?
Are we seeing evidence that
they are developing dispositions
about AI that are
empowering for them,
or do they find it as being
intimidating or not for them?
So there's a lot of questions
that we're trying to assess.
And then when we have
something we think is solid,
then we make it
available for free.
It's all Creative Commons.
Our goal is just to help
empower teachers, non-profits,
get these materials out
there and share them freely.
SARAH HANSEN: But
again, no matter how
good robots or AI get,
they're no replacement
for the real thing.
CYNTHIA BREAZEAL:
I think a lot of AI
has assumed when
you're trying to build
the social and emotional
qualities into technologies,
it's about the robot.
And I'm like, no,
it's about the people
because this is what
people need to engage.
The more deeply we can
engage of our holistic self,
not just our cognitive
selves, but our social selves,
our emotional selves, our
physical selves-- the more
deeply we can engage,
not surprisingly,
the more successful we are,
the better our outcomes.
So it's to say,
it's not about let's
build machines that look like
people and act like people.
It's, let's build machines
that dovetail with us in a way
that we can bring
forth all of ourselves
to help us achieve
the goals that
are really important to us.
And this is why when we talk
about AI as pedagogical agents,
I'm like, we will never
get rid of human teachers
because they are
essential for children
to know that in this
community of human beings,
adults invest their time
in children's learning
and development.
Like, you matter.
I'm taking time and
energy to do this
because it's that important.
And you are that important.
You know, you just can't
underestimate that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: To take part
in the Day of AI on May 13,
go to DayofAI.org.
You can access free teacher
training and other Creative
Commons educational
materials at RAISE.MIT.edu.
Or you can access them through
our website at OCW.MIT.edu.
You can also find Cynthia's
free and open teaching materials
from her MIT courses
on our website.
Thank you so much for listening.
Until next time, signing off
from a galaxy not too far away,
I'm Sarah Hansen from
MIT OpenCourseWare.
Chalk Radio's producers
include myself, Brett Paci,
and Dave Lishansky.
Scriptwriting assistance
from Aubrey Calaway.
Show notes for this episode
were written by Peter Chipman.
The RAISE online publication
was shared on MIT OpenCourseWare
by Sharon Lin.
We're funded by MIT Open
Learning and supporters
like you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]